[Musica]
fino a 10 anni fa ero no sciatore
professionista sci di fondo fatica e
sudore
ho gareggiato per più di vent'anni dal
1988 al 2008
ho vinto tutto quello che c'era da
vincere E tutto quello che uno sportivo
possa Sognare di raggiungere medaglia
olimpiche un oro un argento titoli
mondiali più di 30 titoli nazionali
e rosannato da migliaia di tifosi di
ogni nazionalità avevo fame denaro
notorietà per vent'anni
e poi sono tornato qui dove tutto è
iniziato
sono nato 52 anni fa a Bosco Chiesanuova
un paesino a pochi e decine km da qui
sui Monti Lessini Qui la gente alleva
bestiame taglia la legna e gestisce
qualche locale visto
se in estate e sia in inverno visto che
i turisti non mancano Sì perché questo
Questo posto è un gioiellino incastonato
tra Boschi Prati e alpeggi di mucche
a voler essere preciso Io sono nato in
una Contrada fuori paese da piccolo casa
mia fissava il centro del paese
abitavo in mezzo a Prati e valli che
finivano direttamente dentro i boschi
fine anni sessanta i tempi in cui ancora
i bambini giocavano con i legni e tanta
fantasia
dalle signore un Altopiano sembra un
grande panettone con dei lunghi vari
pieni di faggio e Abeti che scendono
verso la pianura ed è in mezzo qui
tronchi che ora io mi perdo
lo so che vi state chiedendo perché sono
tornato nei boschi dove sono cresciuto
dove seguivo mio padre che faceva il
guardia boschi e non sono rimasto là là
nel mondo dove lo
sci ti dà cosa tutto se tutto sembra
figo Tutto sembra Wow
perché mi sono innamorato sì
Mi sono innamorato perdutamente di una
creatura di una creatura selvatica che
una mattina di un inverno di 10 anni fa
Mentre scendevo una fitta foresta di
Abeti Rossi e Faggi incrociato il mio
sguardo la catturato e l'ha trascinato
giù negli inferi
e lì come dice il video in mezzo alla
mia puzza di marcio ho finalmente capito
chi voglio essere
non capita tutti i giorni che un lupo ti
apre gli occhi e ti faccia cambiare
completamente vita
così ho deciso di imparare ad ululare
sono andato in Slovenia a Lubiana per
apprendere al meglio come farlo non deve
essere né troppo lungo né troppo intenso
né troppo forte
i miei lupi slavici Giulietta mi
rispondono
Sì mi rispondono
sludge è un lupo sloveno grosso possente
h percorso più di 2.000 km prima di
fermarsi in Lessinia dove ho incontrato
Giulietta lupo appenninica una femmina
in dispersione dal centro Italia
la mia copia Alfa ha scelto la Lessinia
come loro nuova casa proprio in
concomitanza di quando ho appeso lì sia
il chiodo
Beh Nulla succede per caso
quando pensavo che tutto fosse finito
che la mia vita non avesse più senso che
senza liscia i piedi non potesse più
sentire l'adrenalina un ululato e mi
sono riaggrappato alla vita la mia
seconda vita
la prima volta che mi hanno risposto ero
in mezzo al bosco da solo sono spesso
nel bosco
quando vado indosso sempre gli stessi
abiti non li lavo mai
Mi rivolgo li mettono in una cassettina
di legno presente quella dove si mettono
il vino si mette il vino quella e la
sotterro
faccio lo stesso con tutte le
attrezzature che uso per monitorarli
fototrappole binocoli bussole torce
metto tutto dentro la cassetta perché
devono odorare sempre e solo di
selvatico
dicevo che la prima volta che mi hanno
risentito ero solo
era un fine settimana di dieci anni fa
ed ero andato a dormire nella foresta ho
montato la tenda ho steso il sacco a
pelo e ho acceso il fuoco mi sono
allontanato nel buio
o divaricato le gambe mi sono portato le
mani alla bocca o ispirato a fondo e
dopo una ventina di secondi da quel mio
primo ululato ne ho fatto un altro e poi
è accaduta la magia
dal Vaglio di fronte a me ho sentito
tornare come un Gemito e più passavano i
secondi più Diventava sempre più
opprimente
un ululato vero
colpivo alle spalle dietro a me i miei
lupi mi stavano rispondendo
così ho deciso di urlare una terza volta
la risposta è stata subito corale
Oggi la mia vita è questa a me piace
dire che sono un guardia Boschi della
Lessinia e sia durante il lavoro sia
durante tutto il mio tempo libero i lupi
sono la mia nuova famiglia
Li seguo gli ascolto e ci parlo
Il lupo è un animale comodo scomodo
molto scomodo però tanto allusivo
opportunista lui se ne frega del clamore
che provoca quando arriva in un posto e
Credetemi ne fa tantissimo
lui se ne frega delle reazioni della
gente fa semplicemente il lupo come ha
sempre fatto da millenni
e per questo che viene maledetto
Ecco perché voglio essere un lupo
perché oggi io il campione olimpico
quello che ha vinto tutto quello che è
salito lassù Sul tetto del mondo
Voglio essere maledetto per essere
solamente me stesso
sapete Però ne ho fatto uscire a fondo
Chi di voi lo pratica sa che pochi altri
sport ti consentono di stare così a
contatto con la natura non servono
impianti di risalita non servono
particolari infrastrutture basta
infilare liscia ai piedi e spingere in
mezzo alla natura Ecco la natura
oggi mi accorgo quanto magari
inconsapevolmente sia sempre stato
circondato dalla natura quando
gareggiavo non me ne rendevo bene conto
ma ora appena posso esco e mi perdo nei
boschi E sorrido
Forse sono un lupo Da sempre perché non
sto bene da nessun'altra parte se non in
un bosco col rumore dei miei passi il
profumo del muschio e dove non vedo
l'ora di ascoltare un ululato
e quando accade mi accuccioli
in ginocchio respiro fondo chiudi gli
occhi Chiudo gli occhi e mi sento uno di
loro
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]